I want to talk briefly about histograms as a special case of a bar chart.
The key difference is whereas the bar charts we discussed so far
were defined over 2D data, the histograms look at 1D data.
That is, there is only one dimension of data that is being plotted.
Let me start with an example.
Here is a fictitious data set about annual income.
Suppose at some company I asked software engineers how much annual income they make.
Again, this data set is contrived.
Of the nine people I asked, here is the survey of different annual salaries.
In the histogram case, I make a bar chart that concerns itself with only one thing,
which is called "frequency," which is short for "count,"
that will group these salaries into three different buckets--
from $120,000 on, $130,000 on, and $140,000 on.
What the bar chart plots is the frequency at which people asked fall into the different categories.
Specifically, I am asking you what is the count for the salaries that fall into
the $120,000 to $130,000 bucket. Please answer it here.